our next guest is an atlanta local who
made headlines when he went from
rapper to cat trapper sterling davis
operates trap king humane cat solutions
out of his rv in atlanta georgia
the organization provides shelter and
other humane medical services
for stray cats please welcome to the
show with ross and myself
sterling hi sterling
hey drew how you doing hey ross how you
doing how y'all doing
we're so good and we're so happy to see
you today
yeah you know we we rescue animals as
well we both have rescue animals so this
is
so important to both of us for starters
just thanks for all you do for all these
cats yeah
thank you thank you all for rest for
having rescue pets thank you
please tell us about your story how did
you evolve
into this magnanimous work that you do
i always loved animals especially cats
but i was always into music and in
between music tour
i saw an ad i was just trying to find
something to do i saw an ad to help
scoop litter
and i ended up going just to do it for a
couple months until i went back on tour
but i
ended up falling in love with it and i
ended up staying i had to call my
buddies and tell them hey
i'm not coming back because i'm rescuing
kitties and they like
what i love you went from rapper to
rescuer now we've rescued so maybe we'll
go to wrapping next drew maybe that's
what we should do well maybe not but
like here's the question
uh i know that you have uh some help
there in the atlanta area with uh with
uh some of your rescue
the stuff that you do but how do you pay
for the food or the surgery where does
that
those funds come from yes well i
actually believe it or not and i'm in
here right now i live out of my rv
my vehicle at first i started with the
conversion van and i lived out of that
because there's no way i could afford
rent and cat surgeries at the same time
so
i actually from donations and actually
atlanta humane society
they saw what i was doing and reached
out to me and they started to do some a
lot of my surgeries for free
because uh like i said it can get real
expensive paying for surgeries and
that's one of the reasons why i stay out
of a vehicle because
renting cat surgeries wasn't gonna work
at the same time and just so we can
clarify
for anyone who's kind enough to be at
home watching and our vffs
may i make sure i'm getting this right
you
rescue the cats and then you make sure
they get spay or neutered
and then release them yes so
tnr is trapped new to return so it's the
humane alternative for death and
euthanasia for stray and feral cats
so catch the cats in humane traps
i take them to atlanta humane society i
get them spayed
neutered vaccinated and i returned them
back to their colony so this prevents
overpopulation and spreading disease
a lot of times there may be some cats
that's too friendly to go back outside
they would rather be in a forever home
that's
fur ever home oh yeah
he's punny i'm glad you're so nice i was
worried you'd be a little catty
ross loves a pun and i love it when you
do it
i'm so i'm blown away by what you do i
just think this is so incredible and
that you do it by yourself
it's true and we're not the only ones
ross
it turns out that the cat food brand
smalls
which by the way please go on their
website
very chic wonderful company
um they have human grade cat food
and they are donating 5 000
worth of that high protein human grade
cat food
for you and your furry friends and they
customize subscriptions and allow you to
have this fresh nutritious
cat food but they'll deliver it right to
you as well
of course are you serious to me
thank y'all so much i'm gonna feed a lot
of colonies with that please believe it
i know how much of your own resources
you pour into these animals so
ross and i want to just throw in an
extra three thousand dollars for any
other things you might need along the
way
and just show our gratitude for what
you're doing in the world
and you're really an inspiration to us
all sterling
yeah cat's what i'm talking about
thank you all so much that is amazing
really seriously i'm drew i've been a
huge fan of yours forever
watched everything you do so to be
sitting here talking to you about cats
right now is amazing to me thank you
ross thank you so much this is
this is amazing y'all thank you so much
enough about us thank
you yeah you're the reason we're doing
this right now so it's all about you
sterling thank you so
much
[Music]
you